I don’t think there’s ever been a video
game quite like Spore.
Released in the late 2000s, the game lets
you create and then guide a lifeform from
a microorganism in a tidepool to an advanced
creature in a galaxy-spanning civilization.
Being able to, essentially, design and play
as your own speculative creature really blew
my mind when I was younger.
I remember spending hours trying to make my
creations as detailed as possible, and coming
up with fake scientific attributes about how
they functioned in the ecosystems around them.
Of course, you could also use Spore to create
bizarre monstrosities, and throw the rulebook
of biology out the window.
After all, the final game was certainly not
always a, uh, scientifically accurate depiction
of evolution, and often cartoonishly over-exaggerated
the stages of life.
I also know a lot of content was cut during
its development, which disappointed some.
Yet for all its eccentricities, Spore remains
an evolution simulator that’s quite nostalgic
to many — myself included.
And the game does explore a number of the
principles of evolution and biology, albeit
in a simplified manner.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
make a creature and play through the game
ourselves to gain an understanding of how
this virtual race for survival relates to
real scientific laws.
And as an added challenge, we’ll try to
keep our creature within the parameters of
plausibility — as much as such a thing is
possible in Spore.
So, let’s begin our multi-billion-year voyage
through this simulated universe…
The game opens on a swirling spiral galaxy.
The opening screen really sells the potential
of the journey you’re about to embark on.
From this distant perspective, anything seems
possible.
We have a number of gleaming planets upon
which we can begin our odyssey of adaptation.
This particular world seems like a good fit.
Like Earth, it seems to have primarily green
plants to match the light wavelengths of its
host star.
It’s worth noting that in Spore, as in our
own universe, alien planets might have completely
different colored foliage depending on their
star’s wavelengths.
We’ll call this world ‘Planet Curious,’
and kick off the simulation.
The game begins with a sequence of an asteroid
hurtling past the planet’s host star, and
towards the planet itself.
Breaking through the atmosphere and raining
down into the sea, the asteroid carries with
it hidden microorganisms.
The concept of microorganisms surviving in
space for long periods might sound like science
fiction, but certain species of tardigrades,
or ‘water bears,’ can indeed survive the
vacuum of outer space.
The idea that a similar microorganism could
hitch a ride to another planet on an asteroid
is a genuine scientific theory.
And with the lifeform we’ll be guiding emerging
from the rubble, the first stage of Spore
has officially begun.
While this section of the game is called ‘Cell
Stage,’ it seems to be a multi-cellular
organism from the very beginning.
Our species begins life on this planet drifting
through the tidepool, feeding on pieces of
algae-like plant matter.
On Earth, many tardigrades live their lives
in a similar manner, locating and feeding
on clumps of wayward algae cells for sustenance.
As a heterotrophic lifeform, our microorganism
cannot produce food within their body, and
must regularly consume plant matter to continue
functioning.
Our herbivore’s mouth appears to be that
of a filter feeder, and resembles that of
Rotifers on Earth.
Rotifers are among Earth’s most successful
microscopic filter feeders, vacuuming up plant
matter using their swirling mouth-parts.
And if our microorganism wants to get lunch,
they’ll have to be the first in a rapidly
expanding line.
For other emerging herbivores are after the
same resources, and when resources are limited,
competition begins.
And so, within this tidepool, the first race
for survival on Planet Curious is underway...
If our lifeform is going to survive, they
need to adapt.
Entering the cell editor, we can see that
thus far, we’ve been navigating the tidepool
using a single flagellum: a long, whip-like
structure that a wide range of microorganisms
use for locomotion.
Some microorganisms actually possess multiple
flagella to propel themselves along — a
strategy we’ll copy with our lifeform.
Our species also evolves a pair of lateral
spikes to fend off the competition.
Spikes are an extremely basic adaptation,
found on the microscopic level in life like
the heliozoa, whose bodies are surrounded
by sharp projections that can spear other
microorganisms.
Now that our lifeform is looking rather promising,
it’s time we give this particular iteration
a name.
For now, we’ll call them Curiosus Minimus.
Over the course of our multi-billion-year
journey, we’ll see them change quite a bit…
Back in the tidepool, our extra flagella have
helped us outmaneuver other herbivores.
Over the eons, our species has grown larger,
and can now feed on the ends of bigger aquatic
plant structures — again, just like certain
tardigrades.
But it’s no longer just herbivores within
this primordial battleground.
At every turn, newly emergent carnivores try
to snap at Curiosus Minimus.
These early hunters resemble some of the oldest
predators in Earth’s fossil record from
the Cambrian era.
Nectocaris is a notable example of an early
carnivore — and really does look like a
Spore creature in most reconstructions.
With all sorts of unfriendly customers swarming
the waters, the spikes of Curiosus Minimus
are an invaluable adaptation.
Over millions of years, a new trait arises
in the form of navigational appendages the
game calls cilia.
On Earth, the term ‘cilia’ refers to hair-like
structures found on the surface of various
single-celled organisms.
In Spore, cilia are clearly something different,
analogous instead to the tiny, primitive fin
structures present on certain ichthyoplankton.
And with our new fins, the tidepool has never
been easier to navigate.
So far, we’ve subsisted entirely off plants.
But in the interest of documenting a wide
variety of behaviors, I’m going to steer
our lifeform down the path of the omnivore.
In Spore, this is possible through the development
of a proboscis, or proboscis as it’s sometimes
pronounced.
On Earth, various animals feed using a proboscis,
both above the waves and in tidepool-like
environments, as is the case for the Phyllodoce
lineata, a species of worm that uses its strange
mouth to feed on smaller organisms.
With our new mouth, would-be attackers are
now a potential source of nutrition.
Over the next several million years, our species
flourishes — developing a second pair of
fins for navigation, and earning the new name
of Curiosus Aquaticus.
We’re now a far larger lifeform than when
we first began, more comparable to a small
fish than a microorganism.
And other lifeforms have followed suit, with
life on Planet Curious becoming far more sophisticated
in general.
Some organisms can even deliver a sudden electric
shock if Curiosus Aquaticus gets too close.
Mastery over electricity is familiar in our
world, with electric eels using disc-shaped
cells packed into specialized organs to generate
their painful zaps.
While this is a promising strategy, Curiosus
Aquaticus is doing just fine without it — with
our back fins becoming larger and well-defined.
The age of the tidepool is about to come to
an end…
A cartoonish animation shows us that our species
has developed a brain.
On earth, the first brains emerged from interconnected
nerve nets, simple nervous systems that are
still present in some types of jellyfish.
With our developing brain and enviable omnivore
niche, when it comes to swimming in sludge,
Curiosus Aquaticus rules the pool.
But a new stage of life is about to begin
on dry land…
Looking back at our history, we’ve already
had quite a journey: from simple herbivore
to complex omnivore.
And now, the next stage in our evolutionary
journey is evolving legs and crawling out
of the water.
The land-to-ocean transition process was a
complicated one on Earth, and we don’t see
much of it in Spore, although we can speculate
as to how it happens.
Over millions of years, the fins of Curiosus
Aquaticus likely became larger and more muscular
as ecological conditions encouraged them to
spend more and more time at the water’s
edge.
These early explorers likely weren’t the
most graceful on land, and still lived their
lives very much tied to water, like earth
mudskippers.
But eventually, primitive legs emerged.
And now, with a fresh new color scheme, the
rather strange lifeform we’ll dub Curiosus
Irregularius is ready to leave the water behind,
and take their first steps as a proper land-dweller.
As we enter Spore’s Creature Stage, a loading
screen informs us of the kinds of creatures
we might encounter.
And as always, it looks to be quite an unusual
bunch.
Curiosus Irregularius starts off life on land
living in small, communal nests, and generally
lying low.
On Earth, there are numerous types of species
that build their nests directly on the ground.
But it’s an exciting sign of rising intelligence
that our creature has evolved to live in social
units.
As a generalist omnivore, Curiosus Irregularius
spends much of their time foraging for food,
and scuttling along, unseen, through the grasses.
And they’re not alone on land.
Other species — perhaps distant relatives
— have also made the land to water transition
during this early period.
The game gives us the option to hunt them,
or try and impress them socially using displays
like singing and dancing.
On Earth, all manner of animals conduct similarly
unusual displays — but typically only within
their own species to facilitate courtship
and mating.
But while this kind of cross-species communication
isn’t likely, it’s the system the game
provides us with, so we’ll have Curiosus
Irregularius show off their singing voice
to any creature who will listen.
Over the generations, Curiosus Irregularius
will change quite a bit.
Within the creature editor, Spore gives us
the option to make pretty much any changes
we want.
Like I said before, you can really push your
creature to some pretty absurd limits.
I remember spending hours when I was younger
just testing the boundaries of what Spore
allowed you to do.
While all that is fun, it’s not quite how
evolution works, so we’ll be keeping changes
gradual.
On that note, one ancestral trait I’ve decided
to retain are the stalk eyes.
Eyes at the ends of stalks have their drawbacks,
but they also have their advantages, like
a better field of vision.
And frankly, they’re just fun.
In nature, stalk eye users include certain
crabs, and types of snails, so they’re not
an unheard-of characteristic.
In terms of a mouth, this leech-like suction
mouth ringed with primitive teeth seems like
the most likely to emerge from a proboscis.
Another useful adaptation Spore offers is
a type of projectile venom.
I feel the closest analog to this in the natural
world is the chemical spray of the spitting
cobra, so I’ve placed the poison launcher
in our creature’s mouth.
We can say it’s derived from some kind of
salivary gland, as that’s where most venom
in nature emerges from.
Another shift that might feasibly occur over
millions of years is a change in our creature’s
coloration.
Colors and patterns play a fascinating role
across Earth’s ecosystems.
Some have bright colors as a signal to others
of their kind, or as a warning to predators.
Others have colors that match their environments
to hide or to stalk prey.
Still others have colors and patterns that
resemble other forms of life to reduce their
chance of being targeted.
For our purposes, I’ve decided to stick
with a green pattern that matches our environment.
And watching our creature in motion, I have
to say that while I endeavored to make a vaguely
plausible species, they look a bit horrifying.
I’m still quite attached to them, though.
As ages continue to pass, our species grows
more adjusted to land and begins living in
larger social groups.
Other species on Planet Curious are also changing
and diversifying, some of whom we impress
with our social displays, and others who must
be fended off.
We are still an omnivore, after all, and with
our gnashing teeth and venomous spray, we
represent a formidable threat.
Yet we are a food source for some larger,
more specialized carnivores.
If our species is really going to thrive,
we might have to change our solitary hunting
strategy…
Another age passes, and we can evolve a larger
mouth with more defined pseudo-teeth.
Like many of the mouths in Spore, this one
does look… a bit odd.
I do think it’s cool, however, that the
abilities of these mouths seem to be loosely
inspired by the behavior of real-world animals
— with the songbird-like mouth better at
things like singing, and the crocodile-like
mouth featuring one of the strongest bites.
It’s obviously a simplification, but it’s
a fun detail nonetheless.
Sticking with our horrifying leech mouth for
now, we can also upgrade our poison spit and
our talons, and add a display structure on
our creatures’ shoulders that will help
us show off.
I imagine this feather-like structure evolved
from some kind of rigid plate for the purpose
of attracting a mate.
And while that might sound far-fetched, some
display structures on Earth which have evolved
to attract mates are far more elaborate.
With a new pattern of stripes on our creature’s
legs to help it blend into the tall grasses,
I think it’s time we gave this iteration
the new name of Curiosus Striatus.
And this new chapter looks to be an exciting
one, as our species’ social intelligence
has progressed to the point where Curiosus
Striatus can hunt in a coordinated pack.
With this critical advantage, our species
is now frequently able to outcompete lineages
that were once higher in the food web.
On occasion, the pack wanders into more trouble
that it can handle.
At one point, a group of Curiosus Striatus
are crushed under the foot of an Epic, a type
of giant monster that I remember being one
of the scarier parts of Spore when I was younger.
At another point, we wander out to sea and
are swallowed by a creature from below — another
part of Spore that I distinctly remember finding
terrifying.
But with each new generation, our pack-hunting
omnivores are getting smarter…
And as the pages of evolution continue to
turn, it’s possible that Curiosus Striatus
might become bipedal.
Bipedalism is a form of terrestrial locomotion
where an organism moves by means of its two
rear limbs.
While we associate this kind of walking with
humans, all sorts of animals do it for all
sorts of reasons.
In dinosaurs like the theropods, for example,
bipedalism is thought to have emerged to free
up their front limbs and allow them to grasp
fast moving prey.
We can imagine that primitive grasping digits
might emerge in our species for the same reason.
With a new mouth and more complex display
structures, this is a big shift for our lifeform.
And as is sometimes the case in Spore, while
our design might look pretty streamlined while
standing still, in motion, it looks… a bit
unusual.
Oh well.
With a new name to celebrate its grasping
digits, Curiosus Digitatus is born.
And with our new hands, fruit that was once
out of reach is now quite accessible.
The social interactions of Curiosus Digitatus
are also more complex, moving in larger packs
across the vast open plains.
With our coordinated movements and theropod-like
anatomy, we’ve never been higher up on the
food web than we are right now.
Some Curiosus Digitatus will even, on occasion,
pick up sticks and hold them in their hands.
While for the moment this is just the product
of curiosity, it’s similar to the behavior
of early primates that gave rise to the first
hominids.
With these grasping appendages encouraging
their inquisitiveness, Curiosus Digitatus
are on the cusp of evolving higher intelligence.
Curiosus Digitatus now live in larger nests.
They can impress just about any species through
their displays, and hunt just about any species
with their claws, fangs, and venomous spit.
And with another cartoonish graphic conveying
that our brains have once again become larger
in size, the final stage in our development
is upon us.
It’s worth noting that while in Spore, your
creature evolves along a direct path toward
advanced intelligence, real evolution is of
course more meandering, with organisms adapting
to physical changes in their environment,
and not necessarily increasing in intelligence
size over time.
But having a more streamlined journey through
evolution makes Spore more exciting.
Speaking of which, entering the creature creator
one last time, we can make the final upgrades.
These include a four-part mouth, which is
similar in some ways to the mouthparts of
certain insects.
Our fingers are also longer and more dexterous
— with the critical beginnings of an opposable,
thumb-like digit — and our display structures
are more extravagant than ever.
Finally, our posture has become more upright.
This remarkable iteration has earned the name
Curiosus Sapiens.
Looking onwards towards the future, the various
social units of Curiosus Sapiens will continue
to thrive and achieve greater complexity.
These intelligent omnivores have come a long
way from their tiny, filter-feeding starting
point.
Looking back through our history once again,
it’s been a long and winding road to reach
this point.
The stages after cell and creature all about
technological development, so we won’t be
covering them — at least in this video.
Watching a creature evolve in Spore remains
a pretty special experience.
Despite the game’s age, I often see people
posting new stuff they’ve made online.
I know that Spore almost had more features
and more realism in it, and while it’s a
shame those elements got cut, the simulated
galaxy we’re left with is still pretty unique.
I think part of what keeps people coming back
to this game is that the experience is very
much what you make it.
You can push the creature creator to its absolute
limits and make absurd monstrosities, or you
can try to stay within the lines of plausible
biology.
It’s up to you.
I’d love to see another high-profile game
tackle something similar, as I feel there’s
real potential for a modern, more science-based
take on this concept.
But for now, we can always fall back on the
weird and wonderful possibilities of Spore.
As always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support to help make these videos possible
by liking, subscribing, and hitting the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.